the Game of Thrones Season 7 trailer
begins as all great trailers do with a
quick geography lesson Queen Cersei
stands on a map and says there are
enemies to her east to her west to her
south and to her north there's Daenerys
Targaryen with her invading army this
King euron greyjoy with his Ironborn
fleet there are the sand snakes and
Alayna in the reach and in Dawn and in
the north as King Jon Snow
we learn a lot about each of these sides
in the trailer and about other cool
stuff besides so let's have a quick look
at what this all means for the future of
Game of Thrones
first off Daenerys Targaryen finally
arrives at Westeros this is a moment
that Dany has dreamed of for years that
fans have awaited for years ever since
the first book came out back in 96
Daenerys was born here at Dragonstone
the ancestral home of the Targaryen
dynasty that had ruled Westeros for
three centuries until Robert Baratheon
took over and Danny had to flee with her
brother Viserys all her life had a knee
long to return to a home and to her
birthright the Iron Throne and now after
six seasons and five books and twenty
long years her time has finally arrived
to conquer Westeros this table in
Dragonstone was made by Danny's ancestor
Aegon three hundred years ago a map with
no borders to show that the Seven
Kingdoms is truly one realm for one king
to rule alone or in this case one queen
there ain't room for two on the Iron
Throne
so to defeat Queen Cersei Dany brings
with her three dragons a Dothraki horde
an unsullied army fire and blood Danny
says she was born to rule the Seven
Kingdoms but is she even the good guy
here from another perspective she's a
crazy dragon lady from across the sea
attacking the kingdoms with foreign
soldiers burning people alive with
flying monsters is she really the hero
danny's often compared to her father the
cruel Mad King Aerys will Dany be a
force for peace or will she go down her
dad's dark path fortunately Dany has
many supporters and
visors around her including grey worm of
the unsullied and Miss and I who get it
on in the trailer despite the fact that
grey worm is a eunuch and this Tyrion
Lannister who has valuable political
experience in King's Landing and who has
a curious relationship with Dany's
dragons some fans think that Tyrion
might ride at Dragon Dany also has Varys
though he's barely visible in the
trailer and other characters like Daario
and kin Vera aren't there at all these
last seasons of Thrones move so fast
that there isn't even time to kill off
the minor characters before they're cut
from the story but someone we do see is
Melisandre she's at Dragonstone which is
a bit of a surprise last we saw Mel she
was exiled from Winterfell by John and
Davos for the whole child murder
kerfuffle last season it seems that Mel
then went to dragonstone where Danny is
Mel has a pretty flaky record when it
comes to supporting leaders first she
says Stannis is the Saviour then John
maybe now she'll support Daenerys who
other red priests say is the hero azor
Ahai Dany and Mel do both love flames so
they should get along like a house on
fire
or like a girl on hmm anyway Dany has a
great squad and a huge army and in the
trailer she goes on the attack we see
Circe's Lannister soldiers attacked by
Daenerys as unsullied in a castle that
looks unfamiliar it's got Lannister
heraldry painted on an archway though so
this might be Casterly Rock
the home base of the Lannisters which
we've never seen before in either the
books or the show The Rock is a massive
fortress built into a mountain in the
westerland's and it's apparently never
been taken before if Casterly Rock Falls
to Daenerys that would be a huge blow to
house lannister this spot on the map by
the way seems to read see a maybe
supporting the idea that this place is
Casterly Rock
so Daenerys is Circe's Eastern enemy her
enemies to the south are Daenerys as
allies the sand snakes of dawn and a
Lenna of the rach these guys don't
actually appear in the trailer which is
a strong hint that they
not last long in season seven the first
big sand snakes episode was the least
popular episode in game of thorns
history and ever since the show runners
seemed to be pretending that the dawn
story line never happened with only a
brief couple of scenes in season 6 so
the sand snakes will probably be quickly
swept under the rug in season 7 though
hopefully Elena Tyrells still has some
fire in her
Elena's whole family was murdered by
Circe last season so now Elena has
nothing to lose she's out for revenge
also we see ilaria sound making out with
Yara Greyjoy which is fun though the
last person who will Arya kissed Circe's
daughter Marcella caught a pretty bad
case of death by poison so Yara might
want to be careful where she sticks her
bits but also Circe has not forgotten
the murder of Marcello by the sand
snakes there are the lot of scores to
settle in season 7 another battle in the
trailer seems to take place in the south
because Danny's Dothraki are fighting
men not from house lannister
but from house Tarly this Bowman looks
just like the tally heraldry house tally
is led by randyll Tarly said to be one
of the greatest military minds in
Westeros however it looks like Randall
makes the huge mistake of trying to
fight the Dothraki not in a castle but
in the open field that is like the one
thing you should never do against
mounted Dothraki because these guys can
run your ass down shooting arrows from
horseback jumping from one horse to
another dual wielding Iraq's running
literal circles around you this is not
what you want so Randall [ __ ] up and
will probably die which actually is
pretty lucky for Randall son Sam well
Sam if you remember to Randall's
favorite toy last season the Valyrian
steel sword hearts pain and Randall
might not forgive that he's threatened
to kill Sam before and after the theft
of his beloved sword he might finally
decide to quote home to Sam down like
the pig he is so maybe not such a bad
thing if Sam's dad dies meanwhile Sam
can keep studying in the Citadel of the
maesters he and Gilly might uncover all
sorts of secrets in the
Citadel library in this promo image
Gilly is reading a text about azor Ahai
the hero prophesied to save the world of
the Citadel is home to Westeros as
greatest experts on history and
astronomy and on medicine which could be
very important for Jorah Mormont in the
trailer we see his armor mode from
within a wooden door badly infected with
the disease greyscale Jorah is slowly
turning into a stony zombie but there
might be hope of a cure at the Citadel
and this raises some really cool
possibilities because in the books
there's a character called a Victorian
Greyjoy who gets an infected wound in
his arm he's healed in a magical ritual
and afterwards his arm is left bloody
and blackened charred and smoking but
apparently stronger than ever
maybe the curing of Joris infected arm
will do something similar give him a red
smoking super-powered arm just like
Victarion and like Hellboy and the ninja
gayden guy and c3po this might not be
likely but it would be super cool so
that's what's going on in the South
Circe's enemies in the West seem to
refer to the Ironborn under King euron
greyjoy
that's a Greyjoy ship we see in the
trailer
Cersei calls her on an enemy but an
alliance between Cersei and Iran is
possible that might be Euron in Circe's
throne room in the trailer
Cersei desperately needs some allies
surrounded as she is by enemies on all
sides and with the Iron Islands behind
him euron greyjoy could prove a powerful
friend in the trailer we see him attack
what seems to be Daenerys his fleet the
Targaryen Tyrell and Martell ships we
saw at the end of season 6 and this
battle could be huge Theon Greyjoy is
here Yara and ilaria are probably there
and judging by all the fire Danny's
dragons might be involved we've seen the
Dragons kick ass at sea before but
Ironborn are famously dangerous on water
and Euron no doubt has some tricks up
his sleeve
so this naval battle could get pretty
crazy so Euron may be a useful Ally for
Cersei but otherwise she's running
pretty
on friends having blown up half the
capital last season as tensions rise and
her enemies close in it'll be
interesting to see if Circe shows any
remorse or regret over her crimes or if
she'll remain defiant to the end
speaking of which there's a lot of
speculation over house as he may die a
prophecy in the book suggests that
Cersei will be killed by her brother
Cersei thinks this means Tyrion but some
fans think Jaime will be the one to kill
his sister so maybe so sees most
faithful protector will prove to be
Craig or Clegane the undead Mountain who
now looks like a medieval Darth Vader in
some new black armor it's cool how the
armor has an image of Circe's crown on
the chest previous Kingsguard armor has
shown a Targaryen dragon a king's crown
or the faith's star this emblem puts
Cersei front and center so she's been a
focus of a lot of the HBO promos lately
this season might be a big one for her
so we've seen Circe's enemies to the
east south and west when she speaks of
her enemies to the north we get a shot
of aya Stark
traveling alone the show has spent two
seasons training eyre as an assassin but
with Walder Frey dead her priority now
seems to be to return home to Winterfell
ever since season one aya has been
cruelly separated from her family and
it'll be a hugely emotional moment for
her to see Sansa and bran and Jon again
first though she might reunite with
another close friend the direwolf
Nymeria who I had to live in the
Riverlands back in season one there are
hints in the books that while aya has
been off training Nymeria has been busy
- growing from a cute little dog oh into
a monstrous man-eating she-wolf leading
a huge pack of wolves across the river
lands Nymeria is not just a symbol of
Aya's stark heritage she's a symbol of
how I has changed from an innocent young
girl to a violent ruthless killer
hopefully aya will find some peace this
season also speaking of bran he and Mira
aren't in the trailer but they're
presumably still heading down to
Winterfell
since benjin dropped them off for fair
distance short of the war
well Muir has a long way to drag bran
home which could get tricky with the
zombies chasing them though on the
upside when they arrive Mira's glutes
will be incredible but at Winterfell
itself we see Circe's main northern
enemies King John Snow and Sansa Stark
with Brienne and the Lords of the north
and Davos and Littlefinger lurking down
in the shadows we see him in the
Winterfell crypts with John and John
slams Peter up against a wall did
Littlefinger just say something about
John's mother they are standing next to
the statue of Lyanna stark and while we
found out last season that John is Li
Anna's son John doesn't know that yet
that maybe Littlefinger does also John
attacking Peter mirrors are seen in
season 1 when Ned did the same thing the
Starks touchy the little finger is also
whispering in the ear of Sansa who he
seems to be trying to turn against John
on the one hand Peter has a point
Sansa is the oldest true bond child of
Ned Stark
apart from bran whoever on thinks is
dead so by riots it's Sansa not John who
should rule the north on the other hand
Peter is a sociopathic scheming creep
who sold Santa's to the Bolton's killed
Sansa's aunt Lysa
betrayed Santa's father Ned and partly
caused the whole war of the five kings
in the first place so it's about goddamn
time that someone killed this guy
already the Davos meanwhile plays the
voice of reason reminding everyone that
all this petty politics is pointless in
the face of the coming war with the
White Walkers it's kind of funny how the
Starks have so suddenly come to trust
this random southerner Davos but it's a
good thing they do because he's one of
the only people talking sense in this
series the HBO promos this year make it
clear that the walkers and the Wyatts
are the big threat to Westeros and in
the trailer it looks like Jon leads a
push against the walkers a group of
people run out beyond the wall including
Jon and torment and possibly Gendry see
how one of the blokes has a Warhammer
Gendry is the bastard son of Robert
Baratheon who famously used a Warhammer
in his rebellion fans have been saying
for years how cool it would be if Kendra
took up a hammer and
emulated his father in battle and with
all the rowing he's been doing he'd
probably be more than strong enough that
shame the weather's so cold though he'll
probably have to keep a shirt on
also we know the hound has joined
barrack and Thoros heading north maybe
those guys are in this group - Brienne
might be there and benjin's out here
somewhere - so this might just be the
greatest all-star team we've ever seen
in Thrones some of the best warriors in
all Westeros fighting together they'll
need to be at their best to face the
walkers and the whites and the long
night to come so there is a huge amount
of stuff happening in Game of Thrones
season 7 and there are only 7 episodes
to fit it all in time is running out
to wage wars settle scores exposed
secrets achieve ambitions unite with
family bring about justice to fight
survive and to fulfill destiny we're
well beyond the books now so no one
knows how this will end and every moment
might just be a character's final scene
make sure to subscribe to old shift X
for more on the Game of Thrones show and
books we've got videos about Arya and
White Walkers and a million other things
if you want to go check those out also
if you haven't read the books before
consider buying them with the Amazon
link below you will not regret reading
deeper into Thrones
this chart is Bice wolf of wallstreet
this Victorian art is by Michael Stein
this Veda art is by Roberta Robert all
of the links are below thank you to the
translators for translating captions and
as ever thank you to the patrons for
making this channel possible if you'd
like updates behind the scenes post
scripts and more from alt shift X
consider supporting the channel on
patreon
thanks to patrons Shaun McGrail
Belladonna Q Bruno ribeirão Tim Barclay
and pound look Cheers